and thanks for your
calls during this first hour when we
open the phones and let anybody talk
about all these different issues
we are going to switch the topic to
conspiracy and on your screen is
professor michael barkin he's in
syracuse and i want to start by first
saying good morning but asking professor
barkin what his favorite conspiracy is
well the favorite conspiracy that i
would have as a scholar of conspiracies
is simply the one that tries to explain
the most
what's the the cover of your book has
the big eye on it what's that mean
well that of course is the reverse side
of the great seal of the united states
and the image is taken off of the back
of the
one dollar bill if you look at a lot of
the conspiracy theories that are out
there
they tend to
regard that so-called all-seeing eye at
the top of the pyramid as a symbol of
the illuminati the secret society who
allegedly are masterminding the new
world order takeover well let me start
by asking you also what a conspiracy is
i would regard a conspiracy belief as
the belief that there is some
organization operating covertly to
reach
evil or malevolent ends
overnight i was telling the audience
earlier i was listening to
this radio program that has millions of
listeners overnight called coast to
coast am george nori
is the host that used to be hosted by
art bell and they talk about ufos they
overnight they had a gentleman on by the
name of alex jones who has a
talk show in texas i think and it's
heard in communities around the united
states and he was talking about the
bohemian grove club as if that's where
it all happens that's where all the
decisions are made there are thousands
of people go there and there's some kind
of a ceremony surrounding an owl and all
that have you followed this at all
yes i i have even though the show is on
past my bedtime but
alex jones has been talking about this
for for quite a while the bohemian grove
of course is a privately owned
redwood grove up in sonoma county north
of san francisco
where every summer there is a
get-together of
the wealthy and
and well-placed all all-male
uh who
get together for
general cavorting socializing lecture
symposia and so on
and an atmosphere that is completely
removed from public scrutiny
alex jones and some others have
suggested for a long time that there are
all sorts of nefarious rituals that go
on and as a matter of fact
a couple of years ago and uh i talked
about this incident actually in uh in in
my book
uh someone who had listened to the
alex jones show about this uh
was arrested
within the bohemian grove very heavily
armed
because he said he was trying to bring
attention to what he thought were human
sacrifices that were
being committed by the elite who
attend these gatherings
what about scotland bones
skull and bones
obviously
gets a good deal of attention
simply because
a it's it's secret
and b
the members are
are people who often turn up in high
places
later in life and we'll certainly
hear lots about it this year because
both george w bush and john kerry were
members uh most of the conspiracy
theories that are that are out there now
tend to place a lot of emphasis on
the notion that there are interlocking
secret organizations that
hold the real power
in the world and because of its secrecy
and because of the
elite background of many of its members
skull and bones is a prime candidate for
that
now i see that you have
graduated from northwestern and you got
a masters and phd from that university
in political science and that you've
taught at syracuse since 1965 and you're
a native of chicago is that all right
that's all correct and before we take
our first call what got you interested
in conspiracies in the first place
what got me interested is that i had
been involved in a research project back
in
the late 80s and early 1990s on
extreme right wing groups in
in america and
obviously a lot of those
uh tended to place a lot a great
emphasis on conspiracy theories but then
as i looked further i began to see
many of the same ideas diffusing out to
the broader culture and
in fact
making appearances in venues that one
wouldn't expect them obviously
mainstream films and television programs
like the x-files
basically
recycle a lot of material that in the
past one would have found only in fringe
subcultures by the way what do you think
of radio shows that do spend every night
talking about ufos and black helicopters
and
folks landing out in area 51 and all
that from other planets and
photographs that they have of flying
saucers and all that is that a good idea
a bad idea
well
obviously
given a
society in which we
we prize freedom of speech
people can
use radio shows for
for whatever they wish
there's no
reason why i would make some kind of a
judgment about that lake zurich illinois
you're on with michael barkin go ahead
please good morning thanks for taking my
call
i tried to call william bennett about
the issue of skull and bones earlier
this week and i talked with your
screener and i told him what i wanted to
ask bennett about and he cut me off so
if the viewers think that we're getting
unbiased
c-span information here uh that may put
that into question a little bit okay
then why are we letting you talk about
it this morning because i didn't really
bring up skull and bones this time when
i asked him i told him yeah but
this morning so maybe that's the reason
why you didn't get on the other time
okay but the other day there was no
topic it was an open topic please go
ahead let's see let's go right ahead
with your question then okay
i'm reading the new american magazine
and that's the john birch magazine
correct
and it has an article about the
bipartisan bipartisan bonesmen
and it's really their point that
secret societies are always inimical to
free societies
and it's impossible to judge whether
elected officials
are acting as public service or have
hidden agendas so i'd like you to cover
that issue please thank you
well there's a a long history of
suspicion
about secret societies in america going
all the way back to the early days of
the republic
when
the targets were frequently
the masons i think
one of the things that
we have to bear in mind here is the
relationship between secrecy and privacy
in a sense a term like secrecy has a
pejorative connotation it suggests
that there's some kind of illicit
activity
that needs to be hidden and that's
inimical to
democratic government on the other hand
we also prize privacy we prize freedom
of association and
uh in
in many respects uh certain forms of
secrecy
and uh privacy are two sides of the same
coin if we don't like
the way in which something
goes on we say it's an example of
secrecy if we wish to protect it we call
it
an instance of necessary privacy
columbus ohio you're on with michael
barkin go ahead please yeah we're
talking about um this conspiracy theory
and
when you see what happened when you saw
what happened to the stock market you
have a 10 trillion dollar stock market
bubble
and
you start looking at let's say you look
at a company worldcom
and right now the big deal is well how
do they
hide 10 billion dollars in fraud well
the question is not how they
hit 10 billion fraud the question is
how did worldcom become
a company worth 350 billion dollars
for that to happen you have to have the
fcc
you have to have the sec
you have to have the audit committee you
have to have the banking committee
you have to have all these committees
run by all these senators all these
governors all these government agencies
have to
be in can some type of concert to allow
this to happen um you wouldn't see this
conspiracy theory is is you know skull
and bones
but there has to be something involved
and it also let me ask you this do you
think everybody gets together somewhere
and makes the decision no no no no no no
no no it evolves it evolves it it in
fact what it evolved when you see the
campaign financing the lobbying goes
skyrocketing goes through the roof well
that's that's that puts
that that power structure into the group
of hands of very few all right professor
barkin what are you hearing you want to
comment on
i think that we need to
make a distinction between conspiracies
on the one hand and other forms of of
joint action on the other
uh collusion cooperation
overlapping
uh interests and and so on uh i i'd like
to reserve a term like conspiracy for
activities that are both highly
organized and intentional
and do you have an example of one that's
highly organized and intentional that's
been successful
actually it's the successful ones that i
haven't looked at in the book because
my focus has been on those conspiracy
theories
that posit the notion that there is an
organization
seeking world control
obviously there have been
genuine conspiracies some of them
successful some of them unsuccessful but
the more sweeping the claims are for
what a conspiracy
purports to do
the more difficult it becomes to
either prove it or disprove it and in my
view
the more skeptical one has to be of the
claims palo alto california good morning
hi
professor barkin
mentioned that the all-seeing eye is
supposedly a symbol of the illuminati i
was wondering
what mainstream historians
think the origin of the all-seeing eye
is
well as a matter of fact
if you go to
the
government website on the on the great
seal which if memory serves maybe
i can't remember whether it's on the
department of treasury site or or some
other cabinet department but
in any case uh there's a quite elaborate
uh
history of the manner in which the seal
evolved and the
the the symbolism uh i i think what uh
has happened in contemporary conspiracy
theories is that a kind of alternative
history has been constructed that ties
it to nefarious conspiratorial
organizations define illuminati
the illuminati were a small
quasi-masonic group founded in central
europe in
1776 by a law professor named adam
weishaupt
it
grew
to
perhaps membership in the low four
figures
largely in german-speaking
parts of central europe it was
associated with a
an opposition to monarchical
absolutism and
because of that it began to attract
the uh the hostility of the governments
in the countries where it was operating
so
by around the late 1780s
it had effectively been suppressed and
put out of business
what has happened since then and
particularly since
the 1790
is that
a body of literature has grown up
claiming that the illuminati in fact
were not disbanded that they had a
continued existence that they exist
today and that they have essentially
been responsible for
much of the disruption in
in world history where do they hang out
so to speak
well if you look at the contemporary
conspiracy theories
they tend to be linked to a range of
of other organizations
the ones that come up with some
frequency are
the trilateral commission the council on
foreign relations the u.n
the
federal reserve
there's this sense of
not a single conspiracy
but of conspiracies in a way nested
within one another like russian dolls
and does the bilderberger group fit in
that too
they certainly do uh and in fact
in the more complex and baroque
conspiracy theories there may be
literally dozens of organizations that
are regarded as
components with the illuminati at or
near the summit of some kind of
conspiratorial hierarchy professor
michael barkin at syracuse university
this morning we go to williamsville new
york you're on the air
oh good morning gentlemen morning i'm
fascinated by the subject because i have
a brother who has a mental disorder
and he's a big uh
conspiratorial theorist he he goes as
far as i think that george bush planned
the 9 11 attacks but i wanted to ask a
professor
is you have a conspiracy but then you
have to have the people who actually
believe in it i find that the irrational
people those who are either paranoid
lazy
they manifest their problems uh
in the fact that someone else if someone
else is
it is someone else's uh
fault that they are failing i don't
think a sane rational person who is in
control of his own devices is a
conspiracy theorist but that being said
brian if you reroll the tape and i
noticed this and you know this is not
going to be popular with your viewers or
anything
i do find that blacks when they call
your thing on the liberal line are all
the ones that talking about well george
bush and they said well you know brian
you asked them specifically well what do
you mean george bush knew about 9 11.
well you know and there's it just is
very and that i think is just
unintelligent not that all are but the
ones that go on to do this are just it
is just infuriating to someone like
me you know who you know takes
responsibility for his actions and you
know it's always someone else's fault
and could he just talk about the people
who believe it not the conspiracy
themselves because
most of them are just silly thanks
professor bargain let me just add to
that so it doesn't it's not strictly a
racial thing i hear all the time when i
listen in and out of these programs
people who sound very rational very
smart and intelligent come up with these
very intricate theories
of the everything from the ufo to the
things we're talking about add that into
the mix and give us uh your your views
on this
yeah i i'm very reluctant to equate
belief in conspiracy theories with some
form of psychopathology i i don't think
there's a
a
a clear relationship one way or the
other
uh i do think that conspiracy theories
perform
certain kinds of
functions as far as the individual
psyche is concerned namely
they provide a sense
of order in the world they provide a
sense that there's a kind of plan or
design
because one of the key attributes of
conspiracy theories is the belief
that nothing happens by accident
and
even if
actions are attributed to
an evil cabal
the notion that there is some kind of
moral order if you will in the world
i think is reassuring particularly in
periods of change and uncertainty
damascus maryland you're on ah yes
about conspiracy theories i think it's
basically used as a political tool
uh i watch uh
c-span i uh
uh research the internet a lot uh uh and
write i recently acquired dish tv and uh
have free speech tv so i i i think i
pretty well know what's going on i'm not
saying i know everything what's free
speech tv it's uh it's a channel on uh
dish network and it shows programs like
democracy now
and a
project censored
it's about the 25 most uh
unpublicized by the major media uh uh uh
stories by journalists that haven't been
put out on the major media
and uh what i've noticed is uh i like
crossfire uh i watch major media um i i
guess because i like debate
and uh
uh whenever paul begala brings up
something that i've researched now he
never brings up the full truth but he'll
bring up a part of it and taco cars
tucker carlson will immediately uh
pronounce uh conspiracy theory
conspiracy theory you know and try to
drain out paul what paul's trying to say
and i think basically uh um it's being
used in our political system as a a
political uh weapon against uh you know
whoever's uh pronouncing the uh
conspiracy theory thanks professor
barkin what do you think
well uh i i think to a considerable
extent your your callers correct uh
uh when a term like conspiracy theory
becomes simply uh a label for
denigrating a point of view that uh
someone disagrees with uh it really
loses all meaning and uh and all
usefulness it it simply becomes a a a a
part of polemical rhetoric
the other point that the caller
mentioned that i think is worth noting
uh has to do with the impact of
technology on on all of this i i wasn't
familiar with uh
the tv channel that he mentioned
uh
but it's it's really of a piece with uh
a great many other
technological innovations such as the
internet that bring
a very much wider range of
ideas and beliefs to public visibility
than were there before professor michael
barkin at syracuse university tampa
florida is your next call go ahead
please
yes sir uh dr barkin i wanted to ask you
if you heard anything about the u.n and
any conspiracy as far as a new world
order
i know there's a lot of americans that
have
changed their mind about the u.n and as
far as our involvement in the u.n
well virtually all
conspiracy theories that talk about
uh a new a so-called new world order
uh give primacy to the to the u.n that
that's been
a motif that's been there for uh uh for
a long time it's hard for me as a matter
of fact to think of a of a contemporary
conspiracy theory that uses the term new
world order that doesn't talk about the
un as having some kind of
a central role
what about something like opec
uh opec has
passed from view perhaps temporarily i
think in a sense there are
fashions in conspiracy theories and of
course
uh in the 1970s when
opec had very much greater control over
the flow and uh and price of oil uh it
it rose to
something close to the forefront of
conspiracy theories but in recent years
it's uh it's moved to the back do you
think when that gas keeps going up over
two bucks that uh we'll start hearing
that again
well here it's gone over two bucks
already but yes i
uh i think that's that's quite likely
there are fashions in conspiracy
theories and
a lot of conspiracy theorists as a
matter of fact turn out to be
extraordinarily adaptable in the sense
that
they can modify
the theories in light of whatever the
circumstances of the moment happen to be
in a moment i'll ask you about what alex
jones says is the impending staged
capture of bin laden we go to atlantic
city new jersey you're on the air
yes good morning uh i listen to alan
jones uh religiously from uh two in the
morning to uh five in the morning on a
real one radio on the internet
uh if anybody really wants information
he is the man who has it believe me
um
i wanted to ask mr barkin
about um
how
the um
the passports of the um
of the um hijackers were found if that
that uh
911 building burned up how nine of the
uh 19 are still alive in um
other countries
and uh how those buildings appear to
have been blown up before uh professor
before you answer let me just ask our
caller
why is it that you believe
what alex jones tells you
uh because he uh he makes a lot of sense
there are just too many coincidences um
about
the whole situation from uh george
bush's um
uh coup
and uh i mean uh totally totally and i
watch a lot of history i watch a lot of
pbs i do not watch propaganda uh as
hitler said it is easier to believe a
big lie than a little bit but let me get
i want to press it a little bit more
though
who is alex jones why does he have the
truth and why is everything that he says
reliable
who do you know anything about him you
know where he was born you know how much
education he's got
i'm i i'm
it just makes sense believe me it just
makes sense it just makes sense because
the other way just doesn't doesn't make
sense and i know there's evil behind
them behind the skull and bones
well let me ask you this he says there's
an impending stage capture of bin laden
do you believe that
yeah everything staged everything that
the skull and bones do is staged
professor
well um
i i guess i i i would ask first what the
basis is for
uh the various assertions about 9 11
because
they really
run so clearly counter to
um everything else that's been reported
but beyond that
um
i guess my own view would be
that
that there is a role played in events by
accident
by
coincidence
by
human stupidity
by goof-ups on the part of authorities
at one point or another
uh
one of the things that makes me
skeptical about
some conspiracy theories is
the degree to which they basically
deny
that there's any role
played by uh
by by accident or incompetence in
in in human events and that seems to me
to run counter everything we
know about history and and and and
politics the fact is that
uh it's hard to stage events it's
particularly hard to stage
um events of
of great magnitude that take place in a
in a in a clearly
public
venue
and
therefore
i think one has to ask
hard questions about those kinds of
allegations
long island good morning hello sir
i think there's a big conspiracy in the
middle east against us and uh if there's
any terrorist attacks the bill should be
on there on their back
all the opecs all the big shots in the
middle east
all the security that's costing us
around the world with our allies it
should be on their back who's conspiring
in the middle east i think all the
countries are saudi arabia egypt
all the middle east countries
would we call that you call that a
professor a conspiracy and is it true
uh
i would be i would be
reluctant to call it a conspiracy uh
uh only for this reason and and that is
that uh
the history of middle eastern politics
suggests
that the interests of the countries that
your caller mentioned
uh are sometimes the same but sometimes
in conflict
it's certainly possible
that groups of countries tend
at a particular time to support
a given policy because their interests
coincide
i don't call that
a
a conspiracy but there's also a great
deal of evidence of
of rivalry and jealousy among these
states
that suggest that any cooperative
arrangement they might have would be
exceedingly fragile
recently the press secretary the
president bush's father wrote a book in
which uh and i have not read it so i've
got to be careful what i say
allegedly accused
lbj of
having jfk
murdered now that's all very strong
language the press secretary i believe
has
either not said anything about it or
left the impression that he doesn't
he's not in on this or i i don't know is
his brother has also
been nominated to head up the medicare
operation
did you read about that and that's i
know you refer to the kennedy
conspiracies in the book and and what
does that do to a story uh what does
that do to the people that believe all
the conspiracies about jfk
well i i know i know of the book uh only
through the news accounts uh i i haven't
read i haven't read it either
but of course because there has been
such an immense literature about
possible conspiracies connected to the
jfk
assassination that there there is in a
way a kind of a
um
a ready-made audience for for any sort
of uh
uh new take on this particularly
one that
on the surface at least is as dramatic
as
as
as this one
i i think that what
um one always has to ask
in a situation like this is
well if this happened or if it happened
this way
how was it possible for it to remain
secret for so long a time clinton
maryland you're on the air hey brian how
you doing today welcome
nice to hear from you what's up doc
um hopefully got enough time for this
and i'll try to make this as quick as
possible
personally i feel you know i agree with
a lot of stuff you're saying about how
you know there's a lot of uh education
that needs to go out a lot of people
need to do some further research i can
hear when people talk about you know the
conspiracy theories rise out of people's
fears and personally i feel the biggest
conspiracy theory out there has been the
conspiracy of religion
and hopefully i have enough time i'll
try and get this out as quick as
possible
um basically what i look at is like
throughout mankind's history the answers
have always been the gods or a specific
god to like almost every question about
the world around us for example there
was there was a god of war there was a
god of lightning there was a god of love
and
for whatever it is i mean mankind just
really didn't understand the world
around them but as time has progressed
you know through science and technology
we have really been getting a lot of
answers to a lot of the questions around
us and pretty much squashing conspiracy
theories like you don't see people
dancing around the fire sacrificing
people to a volcano anymore worshiping
the god of harvest rain or anything like
that because we have a much better
understanding around the world of us um
and and
what i'm feeling is this
the the
taking incarceration the conspiracy
theories that are out there i i honestly
feel that the church is behind a lot of
the stuff out there because it's like
when when you have that respectable fear
of something that is greater than any
man's
ability to control you it's been able
throughout history to be able to control
people caller what church you say the
church what church you talking about no
just in general religion what i'm saying
is for example um if you take back in
the days when people didn't understand
fire okay hey you know you do as i say
otherwise the fire god is going to get
you got it caller thanks professor
barkin what's your reaction
well
it's it's important to bear in mind here
that there are non-religious conspiracy
theories
in other words there's not there's no
inherent or necessary connection between
conspiracy theories and religions some
are religious some are some are
non-religious or even
anti-religious as a matter of fact
they're conspiracy theories in which
organized religion uh is viewed as part
of the conspiracy
what uh i think is worth noting
in regard to your caller's comments
uh is the extent to which conspiracy
theories
do attempt to as i said before
explain and make sense of the world and
that's one of their attractions we're
talking with professor michael barkin
he's at syracuse university do you um
do you yourself get on the web and try
to find these kind of things or
oh yes uh
the
the web has been um
both an enormous generator of conspiracy
theories
and an extraordinary channel for uh
making them available to potential mass
public so yes i do a lot of
uh web surfing where conspiracy theories
are concerned there's a huge amount out
there how do you if they're not if
they're not true and
i mean i don't know whether these things
are true or not but
how do you knock them down if they
aren't
well in the first place i i don't
necessarily see myself as a debunker
here i don't mean you i don't mean you
necessarily i mean anybody i mean how
does this system knock them down okay
that that can become very difficult
because
the more sweeping the claims of a
conspiracy theory are the more it claims
to explain about the world
the harder it is to disprove and there
are a lot of conspiracy theories out
there that are in effect
non-falsifiable that is if you
present to a believer in them
what you regard as evidence that the
conspiracy theory is false
the believer may well say ah but that
evidence was planted by the conspirators
themselves in order to
mislead you and get you on the wrong
track and when that kind of
claim is made you're talking essentially
about
a closed system of ideas that is
basically
beyond issues of proof and disprove
clearwater florida good morning yes good
morning gentlemen
yes my conspiracy theory is that the
democratic party
is behind the new world order if you
think about it in order to have the new
world order you have to have a weak
america you look at the democrats are
constantly trying to cut defense
cut intelligence
trying to bring us in line with like the
european union
everything about them is it it's like
they basically want us to become a state
of the european union
you see bush is like you know we don't
need their permission
and you see all the democrats like oh we
need the internationalists we need to
call her but let me ask you this though
george herbert walker bush was
i think one of the first people to ever
talk about the new world order
and he's a republican well
you know he that was all about the first
gulf wars are you talking about getting
the big coalition no before that i mean
it was part of his whole presidency but
what do you think a new world order is
well basically it's
one government that controls the entire
world so everybody's like basically a
state member of this one basically the
u.n oh we are the whole thing is evil
you know there's evil intention behind
the whole thing what's the evil
intention i don't know if you look at
the
like the bible they talk about it
and it's just it's always been what do
they want to do they want to kill people
they want to you know come out here
there's there's going to be world peace
and everybody's going to be a part of
this one big thing one guy is going to
rise up if you listen you know the you
know the bible that's gonna be satan
i mean do you believe that i don't know
do you
uh not really i mean i haven't seen
really the signs but in order to bring
this about you need to
basically take everyone's guns away in
the country i thought i mean it's
happening in australia they've taken
pretty much guns away from everybody
what do you think professor
well one of the interesting things about
the version of conspiracy theory that
your caller has is
the identification of the conspiracy
with a political party because
most contemporary american conspiracy
theories argue the opposite they they
argue that there's no difference between
political parties or for that matter
between ideologies they would say that
it doesn't matter whether the
president is a republican or a democrat
it doesn't matter whether one is
identified with the right or the left
those are all superficial because one of
the
key characteristics of contemporary
conspiracy theories is the claim that
nothing is as it seems uh
the sort of
of notion that was implicit in an
earlier caller's emphasis on on staged
events so it's unusual for a conspiracy
theory to zero in on a particular
political party
professor has there been any evidence
real evidence that uh there's been a ufo
land here in the united states with
little people on it from some other land
not as far as i am aware of but i
realize that there are
people out there who hold a different
point of view
where is there a this particular spot
that you always hear about area 51 as
they would they have a hangar out there
where they keep all these things well
there
there are a couple of areas that uh that
pop up and the conspiracy
literature one of course is area 51
north of
of las vegas
which has been a restricted military
test site for a long time
another
much less well-known is uh supposedly
outside of
dulce new mexico up near the colorado
border
so
uh they're uh um
you know they're in fact uh is a kind of
uh
uh a sort of geography of uh of alleged
uh
uh ufo sites and then dulcinea new
mexico do they have uh a community
around there that uh you know
features this kind of thing and well
uh
not not as far as i'm aware i'm not
aware that there's an aw that there's
much on the ground to see but the
conspiracy literature on dulce argues
that there's um an underground
laboratory outside of dulce
that's a cooperative venture of the u.s
government and the and the
extraterrestrials and uh that
literature's been out there for a long
time but it's it's uh one that's less
well-known than the area 51 folklore
what kind of a chance would you give
that that's uh really a true story
personally not very much
on a scale of one to ten ten being
certain that there is and one being not
a chance would you give it a one
uh
yeah i i i i don't see any i don't see
any basis for it but
one of the things that happens and this
is again
i think
a kind of an artifact of the internet
age
is that
stories what folklorists might refer to
as urban legends
achieve a credibility in part by the
number of times that they're repeated
the number of times a story is posted on
the
on the internet gives it a kind of
an appearance of credibility
that it would otherwise not have
our guest gets a call now from woodruff
wisconsin for professor michael barkin
you're on the air hi professor um
i've had such a good time watching this
show some of the early callers have been
a real hoot um
are you i'm sorry you look so bored
during some of them um i was just
wondering what kind of uh work you've
done maybe or any sort of conspiracy
theory um research you've done
uh not on the traditional
ufo
kennedy conspiracy all the usual
political you know the infamous they
kind of conspiracies but any sort of
research you've done
on um correlative conspiracies with um
like traditional magical symbols or
magic or schools of magic not
necessarily wicca but more alchemy aqua
medical schools and the connection
between the freemasons and you know like
the the all-seeing eye and things like
that as
not necessarily as being more
social political conspiracies by the way
caller do you believe any of this
yourself um i do but it's more because
quite be honest it makes life fun
uh i i like conspiracy theories i
consider myself more of a fordian and so
ufology demonology and cryptozoology i
just think is very interesting thanks
professor
well i think it turns out that
a lot of people who believe in
political conspiracy theories
are are also
sympathetic towards
excuse me other
examples of what in the book i call
stigmatized knowledge that is
claims uh about knowledge that have been
rejected by mainstream institutions so
that
uh you will find that there are many
believers in conspiracy theories who
as we've already discussed
may have
views about ufos may believe in it
stories about atlantis
may believe in
alternative or unorthodox medical
theories may believe in crypto zoology
and and and so on so that i think the
line
between
political conspiracy theories and
non-political
what one might call rejected knowledge
claims is uh not a sharp one
coming up in a few minutes sam weinberg
who is a professor at stanford will be
uh on this program
and
he will discuss history and whether or
not people in this generation are as
smart on history as they are
back in the early 1920s or the 1800s and
we understand our guest is having
trouble hearing at the moment we'll take
a call from lacombe louisiana next go
ahead please and we'll pass it on if you
can't hear us go ahead okay yes um i
have two sons that belonged to deep
fraternity when they were at lsu
and they had to belong to the friars
which is a club that belongs to the
geeks and the same thing at yale they
they have the skull and bones that goes
with the deep fraternity so i don't
think there's anything very mysterious
about that and all fraternities have
their little secret hand signals things
like that so
that's what i've always you know
heard from my children and the other
thing i was kind of wondering if um
they used to have something called the
king makers back around eisenhower's era
and i was wondering if the professor
knew about that they picked both
parties presidents for the uh republican
and democratic president and business
people you know like great big companies
and they'll pick both and i'm just
wondering if you heard anything about
that all right thanks professor did you
hear that well i had lost the sound for
uh a few seconds so i did not hear all
of the callers basically what she was
saying is that uh she i think she had a
son who belonged to the deep fraternity
and that they also had to belong to the
friars and she said it was nothing the
skull bones nothing but a fraternity
uh and there's nothing more to it than
that what's your opinion on that well uh
i don't know what goes on in in
skull and bones
the thing about any organization that
has restricted visibility that
makes
claims to secrecy is that
it's possible to project onto it
anything that someone on the outside
wishes to whether it's skull and bones
or bohemian grove what are the chances
that the pressure will be so great on
skull and bones that they'll have to
reveal
the inside information before this
election is over
uh i don't think it's going to happen by
then
i think in in time
uh how long i don't know but in time
the information will probably come out
my guess is a lot of it will turn out to
be
pretty frivolous and
and innocuous but i don't think it's
going to happen before the election
galena illinois your next thanks for
waiting
thank you brian for your good work this
is the prairie populist i'd like to
have the professor talk about two books
by professor quigley who taught at
georgetown taught
bill clinton as a matter of fact his
first was
i think called the anglo-american
connection and it's very revealing uh
tracing new york people
i suppose in the uh
upper echelons back to uh english
connections and ultimately ceaseable
road starting the rhodes system
the other i can't is his magisterial
history of the united states in which he
admits being privy to this group
he doesn't identify
saying that they do exist and he
actually is somewhat sympathetic
to their views now
you know
well
i i can't remember the name of that but
maybe if you'd uh mention that and the
anglo-american connection people could
really read up something
uh professional on this and remember
freud said there are no accidents
thanks uh well there there is uh
what might be termed uh uh a at least a
semi-scholarly
conspiracy
literature in other words a conspiracy
literature that does pay some attention
to
the normal
canons of
of
of proof
on the other hand uh
the uh the response to it whether in the
form of uh responses to carol quigley or
or others who write in that genre has
still been a a good deal of of
skepticism because
freud to the contrary notwithstanding
uh i think many of us who study human
behavior
do believe
that that there are accidents
and uh other than in some ultimate
metaphysical sense all things are not
necessarily interconnected
fort collins colorado you're on with
professor michael barkin good morning
good morning um i had heard that winston
churchill knew about pearl harbor before
that happened
and
i was just wondering if you thought that
was a conspiracy that he let it happen
knowing that it would pull the us into
the war thanks
well there there was uh and i suppose to
some extent remains uh pearl harbor
conspiracy uh theory literature
these are what i refer to in the book as
event conspiracies conspiracy theories
that are
intended to
explain uh events that
otherwise
appear
inexplicable or can't
simply be
assigned to
human
folly or accident because it's
psychologically too disturbing for that
the
the problem with pearl harbor of course
was to explain
how this could happen
without some kind of advanced knowledge
on the part of
of some
allied governments it's it's very much
of a piece with some of the conspiracy
theories that have
arisen in the wake of september 11th in
other words how could this happen
without somebody
knowing in
in advance we don't want to believe
that that kind of
event is possible
it's much more comforting for us
psychologically
to believe that someone in authority
knew but
let it happen that is that there was
someone in control hamilton montana good
morning go ahead please hi brian hi mr
barkin or dr bargain uh i've just two
things i'd like to bring up for you to
think over uh it seems to me mr barkins
that
it's your job to know about
you know as much as you can possibly
possibly know about skull and bones and
other
you know secret societies
if you set yourself up as an expert i
would think that you would
you know alex jones is an expert because
he lives he lives
every moment of his life is
is exposing these you know people and do
you believe him by the way hamilton well
i it just resonates it rings true um
but please let me just make this other
point um just because it's a conspiracy
theory
doesn't mean that it is valid now look
at
uh what 40 years has what how much
information 40 years has brought out
about the jfk assassination that was
considered a balderdash you know in the
beginning it's human nature to to look
at things especially
if you are extremely
um
intellectual like mr barkin
uh brian for example if you could bring
somebody
on that isn't so left-brained you know
who is
almost
just closed-minded completely because of
their intellect their intellect is so
strong that they cannot see that there's
truth to this there might it not might
not be completely true not every detail
but the general idea let me give you an
example this morning i was listening to
alex jones on this show coast to coast
a.m he's talking about today
he's talking about bohemian grove and
the importance of all these people
meeting and then he makes a statement
that president bush when he wasn't
president sealed the deal with dick
cheney there at the bohemian grove to be
his vice presidential candidate and when
i was listening i said to myself
vice president cheney was the head of
his committee to find a vice president
why did they need to go to bohemian
grove to settle this deal and and brian
but look at all of the things that we
have found out about like as being
as being uh you know the ceo of
halliburton and things like that we knew
that before the election that's that's
dishonest it's
it's not what's decided not up front
chaney is a very secretive man
you don't know but you mentioned halibut
hides himself you mentioned halliburton
what's secret about that we knew he had
headed halliburton before the election a
conflict of interest nobody will say the
word it is a conflict of interest
for him to be in the oil business and be
a multi-cabineter
all right thanks professor barkin there
you have it
well i'm not sure
i'm not sure what to uh
what what what what to respond to about
the left brain that comment
uh
well i don't know since i'm left-handed
i suppose that makes me right-brained
she thought you should know more about
things like skull and bones well uh
i
let's put it this way i i
i can know
what i think is knowable
uh
but if one traces back the
claims that are made
by those who
say that they're exposing
organizations whether they're skull and
bones or the trilateral commission or
or or or what have you
um
it it turns out that the that the the
basis of evidence on which they are
relying
uh
is uh is extremely questionable
uh even though they speak of course very
often with uh
with great certainty
the fact that uh a particular story uh
rings true
uh or resonates in in
in in the language of of of some of your
callers
may mean that it's a
compelling account but that does not
mean necessarily that it's a it's a true
account one of the great attractions of
conspiracy theories to believers is the
sense of possessing special knowledge
possessing a truth
not available
to others
and
by contrast
devaluing
the
conception of reality that might come
through
either from universities or
mainstream media or or some other source
we're out of time we need dallas texas
for our last call go ahead please you're
on the air hello hi hi uh hello i was in
the military intelligence station at a
space command and
you know i worked in a sensitive
compartment information area you know
all the all the manuals are
compartmentalized within themselves so
it it's very difficult for normal people
even to understand you know they were
given the information to read but you
know if you're very intelligent then
you know you can make connections of the
information information which is you
know called like remote association
so some people that have worked in you
know top secret areas
do know what's you know truly going on
but well but the quick question
are you saying that there are
uh unidentified flying objects and you
know them from reading these reports no
i'm just saying
i'm just saying that things
information like that would even be
it's like an enigma within an enigma you
had to
the the remote associations are so
so far apart
thanks carla we're out of time professor
barking last comment
uh so last comment i suppose would be
that uh
um in
in a world where uh a lot of things are
going on that we don't quite understand
it's comforting to believe that there's
uh someone out there pulling the strings
here is the book that we've been talking
about a culture of conspiracy by michael
barkin he's at syracuse university and
has taught there since 1965 a native of
chicago thank you very much for coming
in this morning it's a pleasure we will
be back with sam weinberger professor at
stanford it's real early out there in
just about four five minutes
we're pleased to be able to introduce
you to another one of the